المكاسب الاوكرانيه في بخموت على قلتها
تحولت بالفعل الى زخم جديد لترسخ وصفه
زيلينسكي للمدينه بقلعه معنويات
الاوكرانيين فالجنود الاوكرانيون اصبحوا
للمره الاولى منذ شهور في موقع المهاجم
وليس الدفاع هذا الزحف لنحو كيلومترين وفر
دفعه معنويه كبيره لاوكرانيا وفي الوقت
نفسه ضربه لروسيا التي امضت ما يقارب
العام في محاولتها لتطويق قاده اوكرانيون
ابدوا املاهم في الاستفاده من دروس معارك
بخموت عند محاوله الهجوم في اماكن اخرى
على طول خط الجبهه البالغ نحو الف كيلو
متر يريد هؤلاء ابقاء قوه الروسيه كبيره
مقيده في بخموت وما حولها ما يمنع اعاده
انتشاره في مناطق اخرى ويساعد على اختراق
خطوطها العميقه والمحصنه عبر اوكرانيا
وفيما القتال مستمر بشراسه داخل ضخمه التي
تسيطر روسيا على الجزء الاكبر منها كانت
كشفت المكاسب الاوكرانيه الاخيره نقاط ضعف
روسيه اساسيه كنقص التنسيق بين تشكيلات
المنتظمه ووحدات فاجنر وضعف التواصل وروح
المعنويه كما تقول صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات